next time they shine your light in the
sky don't go to it the bat is dead bury
it consider this mercy tell me
do you played
you will
hey youtubers is charlie surprise
surprise Zack Snyder was on Conan
O'Brien and released some more Batman V
Superman footage is basically a longer
version of that Batmobile encounter the
timeline of this clip makes me think
that later when he's wearing the full
Batsuit armor and turns the light on
that's him baiting Superman using the
bat signal as a trap for Superman or at
least something to go to him into an
encounter and it's got me wondering you
know from all the trailers all the clips
all the footage they've released it
seems like Superman thinks that Batman
is crossing the line but I wonder what
kind of Hoops he's jumping through
inside his Kryptonian brain they caused
him to think that he has to stop Batman
completely Captain America Big Boy Scout
hates the Punisher someone who kills
villains but Batman doesn't kill
villains so why is Superman in this
movie being so hardcore my only thought
is is that in the wake of Superman's
fight with Zod Batman comes out of
hiding it just starts going apeshit on
the criminals of Gotham like way way
more hardcore than he used to be because
even if you assumed that Batman in these
you know Batman V Superman movies acts a
little bit more like the Frank Miller
Batman in the dark knight returns books
he's still not that bad but they do try
to set up that conflict in those books
between you know Batman thinking that
Superman's going to easy on criminals
not not doing anything when he could be
doing a lot more Superman thinking the
exact opposite about Batman so let me
know in the comments do you think that
Ben Affleck's version of Batman has
always been hardcore where did he just
start crossing the line when Superman
destroyed half of his city going back to
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
after the second Dark Knight film they
basically put all these murderers on
Batman so that they could keep all the
criminals locked up that was part of the
lie because Harvey Dent killed a bunch
of people something Ben Affleck's Batman
is kind of like that's the way he is
perceived in the city even though he's
hung up the cape and cowl for a certain
period of time whenever the movie picks
up he just hasn't had that Bane moment
where somebody out some is a true hero
which i guess is what's going on with
this Lex Luthor art you know doomsday
comes out crazy man in a cape saves the
city with another crazy man in a cape
and a woman in the skirt with a sword
man won't kill God
if yellow will do it
what have you done
Oh
she with you I thought she was with you
zack snyder actually did do an interview
about about all this doomsday stuff is
going on in the trailer people worried
that it's spoiling half the movie he
said that it's really just a small part
of the film and the rumor is is as a big
action set piece in the fourth act of
the film that's going to tee off the
Justice League franchise some people
think that it's bizarro but I do think
it has something to do with the
Kryptonian tech that Luther's trying to
co-opt in related news out next week is
DC week there's going to be a whole
bunch of DC TV stuff and movie stuff
going on I just did a video for it so
i'll put a link in the description just
in case you guys haven't seen it you can
click here for that DC week trailer with
the schedule like next week's schedule
and you can click here to learn all
about the second half of the season in
the flesh zeroing in their focus on tomb
so much more Zoop earth to stuff in the
second half of the season thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight